Hey John, es ist großartig, die Gelegenheit
zu haben, mit dir zu sprechen. Meine erste Frage ist, wie
würdest du erklären, dass CGI-
Animationsfilme wie Toy Story traditionelle Animationen zu betrauern oder zu ersetzen scheinen,
die
wir in den 90er Jahren hatten, wie mit The
Lion King und all diesen  andere Klassiker
und zweitens, was würdest du
Leuten raten, die bereit sind, auf der
Grundlage deiner eigenen Erfahrungen in die Animationsindustrie einzusteigen,
also ja, das war es schon,
mach weiter so und die besten Wünsche an dich,
John, das ist eine großartige Frage, diese beiden
Fragen sind großartig, ich  Ich beantworte
zuerst die zweite Frage, und das heißt, wenn
Sie daran interessiert sind, in die
Computeranimation einzusteigen, ist es zunächst einmal
großartig, es ist eine großartige, großartige Karriere. Ich habe
immer fünf Söhne.
Ich sage jedem meiner Söhne immer, dass es
egal ist, was Sie tun  aber wähle etwas, das
du gerne tust, dann wirst du keinen
Tag in deinem Leben arbeiten. Sie wissen, wie hart
ich meine ganze Karriere gearbeitet habe, aber ich
freue mich jeden Tag darauf, bei
Pixar zu arbeiten, weil ich immer Dinge sehen werde
Das habe ich noch nie zuvor gesehen. Das ist
eines der aufregenden Dinge an der Computeranimation,
weil die Kunstform immer
noch wächst. Der Computer ist unser Werkzeug,
und wir alle wissen, dass es jedes Jahr einen
schnelleren Computer gibt, dessen Chips
mehr Speicher bekommen, als Sie können  Glauben Sie es, Sie
wissen, in den Handys der Leute gibt
es mehr Computerleistung und Speicher
als damals, was den Mann in den 60ern auf den Mond brachte,
Sie wissen, dass das
so weitergehen wird, also sind das unsere Werkzeuge, aber
was ist das Wichtigste, wenn
Sie sich entscheiden  lerne etwas über computeranimation
vergiss die technologie die
technologie unterhält niemals ein publikum
unterhält niemals ein publikum es ist das was
du mit der technologie machst also
ist das wichtigste was du
lernen musst die grundlagen lernen die
grundlagen der kunst lernen nehmen figur zeichnen
perspektivisch zeichnen obwohl du  wissen, dass
Sie mit einem Computer arbeiten werden,
müssen Sie lernen, wie
Sie die Farbtheorie lernen müssen, die Sie
legal kennen, um Farben zu verstehen  Sie müssen
in Animation lernen, wenn Sie anfangen wollen,
Dinge zu bewegen, die Sie brauchen, um
die Prinzipien der Animation zu lernen. Die grundlegenden
Grundlagen, die von
den Disney-Animatoren entwickelt wurden. Sie helfen dabei,
Charaktere zu Objekten zu machen, die Sie durch reine Bewegung
mit Persönlichkeit und Emotionen zum Leben erwecken können
Aber das erfordert
Kenntnisse der grundlegenden
Animationsprinzipien. Wenn Sie
anfangen möchten, Dinge zu einem ganzen
Film zusammenzusetzen, müssen Sie die Filmgrammatik lernen. Die
grundlegenden Grundlagen, wie Sie einen
Film machen. Wie Sie Ihre Aufnahmen einrichten
Es ist
wirklich sehr wichtig, wenn Sie anfangen,
eine Geschichte zu schreiben, müssen Sie wirklich
kreatives Schreiben lernen, und in den Grundlagen der
Drei-Akt-Geschichtenstruktur wissen Sie, dass es
sehr wichtig ist. Diese Grundlagen sehe ich
immer wieder bei jungen Schülern
, die genau das überspringen möchten  Weil ich
mit einem Computer arbeiten werde, wissen Sie, dass sich der
Computer in Ihrer Karriere ständig
ändern wird, diese Tools werden sich immer ändern,
aber es ist was  Was du mit den Werkzeugen machst
, macht dich zu einem großartigen Künstler, es ist das, was
du mit den Werkzeugen machst, die
Filme machen, die die Leute zum Lachen und Weinen bringen.
Es sind nicht die Werkzeuge selbst, also
vergiss die Werkzeuge, vergiss die
Technologie und lerne die Grundlagen
Jetzt war die erste Frage
Computeranimation in handgezeichneter Animation Jetzt
persönlich sehen Ich liebe alle Animationen Ich
liebe alle Animationen richtig und und ich war
sehr aufgeregt. Ich ließ sehen, dass ich
als traditioneller Animator ausgebildet wurde. Ich weiß, wie man
zeichnet und all das Zeug und  Ich habe
alle Grundlagen der Animation von
dem großen Disney-Animator gelernt, also hatte ich
zu Beginn meiner Karriere großes Glück, dass
sie einfach da waren, unsere Lehrer und
Mentoren. Ich war begeistert von Computeranimation,
denn als ich diese
Bilder sah, wurde mir klar, dass
es eins ist  eine wirklich dreidimensionale
Umgebung, und wir konnten unseren
Animationsfilm wirklich so dynamisch gestalten, ein bisschen die
Art von Kameraarbeit, die Sie
beim Realfilmmachen sehen, eines der Dinge
, die wir tun  Bei Pixar, was meiner Meinung nach einen
Teil dessen ausmacht, was Pixar-Filme so
attraktiv macht, ist, dass wir Tools verwenden
, mit denen Dinge fotorealistisch erstellt werden können, aber wir
machen Dinge, von denen das Publikum weiß, dass sie nicht
existieren, von denen wir die Realität nicht reproduzieren wollen, von
denen wir aber einen Schritt zurücktreten  es und
produzieren Sie etwas Nettes Beachten Sie, dass es
existiert, aber dann lassen wir es so echt aussehen, dass
Sie das Gefühl haben, Sie können dort oben greifen
und es berühren. Es ist, als ob
ich wüsste, dass dies nicht real ist  Ich schätze
dies in den Pixar-Filmen in der
Computeranimation. Jetzt liebe ich handgezeichnete
Animationen. Wir haben die Prinzessin im
Frosch bei Disney gemacht, was ein wunderschöner Film ist.
Wir haben den neuen Winnie Puuh-Film gemacht,
der fantastisch ist und daher für mich ihr
Thema  eignet sich für beide
Medien. Ich liebe Puppenanimation. Ich
liebe Tonanimation, wenn Sie die
erstaunliche Coraline von Henry Selick sehen oder wenn
Sie die Arbeit sehen, die Hardman
Animation mit
Tonanimationen macht. Wallace und Gromit, ich meine diese Dinge  sind fantastisch
und sie sind genau für ihr Medium bestimmt,
also wählen wir gerne ein
Thema, das sich wirklich
für Computeranimation eignet, und deshalb gehen
wir auch bei Pixar immer
an die Grenzen unserer Grenzen  immer
die neue Technologie erschaffen, denn
jede Geschichte, die wir erschaffen, jede Geschichte, die wir
erschaffen, enthält etwas, von dem wir nicht
wissen, wie wir es machen sollen, und das ist eines der
spannenden Dinge an der Computeranimation,
sie wächst und
entwickelt
Sie weiter